eu nasci na itália 31 anos atrás numa
cidade melhor com um vilarejo de 1.200
habitantes perdido no meio das montanhas
no norte oeste deitado entre a frança ea
suíça
o vilarejo de 1.200 habitantes na
verdade agora até 1198 porque eu fui
embora no brasil é mesmo a morar nas
costas então já perdeu dois habitantes
que uma parte grande realmente desse
vilarejo acontecer quando eu tinha 4 a
unidade minha vó descobrir que na
biblioteca na frente da minha casa tinha
um curso de violoncelo
aí ela falou isso com minha maia e
comecei a me inscrever nesse recurso
eu não fazia a menor idéia de quem
queira um violoncelo
mais tarde descobri que minha avó fazia
muita idéia do que era
fui na minha primeira aula é conhecido
uma pessoa muito importante que virou
meu primeiro mestre violoncelo e de
alguma forma me o meu pai musical e meu
pai afetivo também eu lembro do momento
que me deu um aceno na mão me deu um
vacilo que é um quarto desse tamanho aí
apoio à mão em cima de se ver uma cela e
tentei tirar um som do instrumento não
saiu nada mais que uma coisa melhor a
jogada mas a sensação de estar
produzindo um som pela primeira vez na
minha vida que não fosse da minha voz
foi uma coisa incrível e aí eu já caí na
paixão total pela música é por esse
instrumento aí voltei pra casa como o
vilão nas costas assim minha avó quando
viu o tamanho daquele instrumento ficou
valorizado não queria mais que eu
tocasse aquilo mas já terá feito e eu
comecei a estudar comecei a estudar e
depois de vários meses de estudos tudo
isto diz tudo eu aprendi a tocar essa
aqui
[Música]
é
ah é
[Música]
é
é ela
[Música]
é
é é
essa foi a primeira música que eu
aprendi a tocar na minha vida e por
coincidência foi a primeira música que
mora em terceiro viu na vida dele quando
tinha quatro anos de idade através da
música eu comecei a conhecer pessoas
muito interessantes ea gente foi fazer
um curso de uma semana um curso
intensivo de violoncelo quando uma extra
bem velhinho é bem de velha escola o
pensamento dele era muito interessante
ele não queria que nada fosse
desperdiçado nada nem na música na vida
e no quintal do lugar onde a gente
estudava tinha várias árvores de avelã
ele não é obrigado a cada dia a passar
meia hora do dia acolher a avelã do chão
ele ficava lá sentado na cadeirinha com
uma varinha de madeira e se você começar
a acolher a melhor que tinha um furo
quando o bichinho entre paulo da marinha
no dedo ao mesmo tempo quando a gente
caminha ele colocava comida no prato
onde você colocava comida no prato se
você colocar uma mágica que você
conseguia comer você automaticamente
encontrava o mesmo prato coloque tinha
sobrado no jantar e se você não comia
isso no jantar você encontrava isso num
café da manhã é uma pessoa muito forte
mas aí eu fui crescendo e cheguei na
minha adolescência é quando tinha 14
anos eu já tinha total vontade de ser
músico ser adulto eu vou ser a música eu
quero chegar aos 30 anos viajando o
mundo tocando ao mesmo tempo eu comecei
a cultivar ainda é muito rebelde assim
há 14 anos eu era insuportável e
adolescência foi punk mesmo eu gostava
de música punk a primeira música que eu
toquei no milan sendo que não fosse
música erudita é uma música party que eu
tirei uma fitinha de uma banda
independente da itália assim ficava no
quarto tocando música party e há 14 anos
também entrei no conservatório que é
exatamente o contrário deste mundo
o conservatório todo mundo é igualzinho
todo mundo é muito careta muito certinho
muito conservador nem imagina o
conservatório na itália
aí eu sempre fui ovelha negra deste
conservatório porque eu gostava de tocar
outras coisas eles não gostavam muito de
mim
aí eu comecei a formar minha primeira
banda a minha primeira banda a gente
tinha uma regra que era a gente ensaia
um dia se um jornal onde há sim um dia
não disse onde irão dizer não não
importa será feriado será natal o senhor
vê o ano tanto faz um dia sim de nojenta
e ensaiando e duas semanas antes do meu
primeiro show nesta banda o mestre
financeiro marco que tinha encontrado
quando tinha 4 anos morreu
eu nunca consegui mostrar pra ele o que
eu tinha aprendido com ele é o que eu
tinha feito como instrumento de
conhecimento dele como tinha
transformado isso
isso foi um marco lembra daquele dia até
agora
depois disso eu encontrei a música
dieese
aí meu pai que virou um parque de s eu
comecei a ouvir john cutrim saxofonista
dia e noite inteiramente tanto é que eu
acho que esgotei minhas horas de sax da
vida não aguento mais ouvir sax
atualmente não tem não tem jeito
reservado do 24º experimentar várias
coisas
eu fui no festival festival de jazz gana
que tem na itália onde tem um curso o
curso era do berklee college of music de
boston
eu fui lá tocando na minha música
professor e ele me deu uma bolsa pra ir
estudar na aberta e aí vou lá eu achava
que minha vida fosse toda já traçada e
estados unidos estudar lá teria feito
coisas pra lá e pronto
se não fosse um ano depois eu estava com
a minha banda inteira essa banda do
ensaio onde há sim um dia não estava num
carro a polícia pelo nosso carro é a
gente no carro eu tinha substâncias que
não eram exatamente legais
nada que fosse meia hora que fosse me
obviamente tinha a china nesse caso é o
policial não gostou ea gente ficou preso
eu e minha banda ficamos presos todos
algemados e fomos na cadeia eu passei
três noites na prisão em turim foram as
três noites mais longa da minha vida e
da janela daquela prisão dava pra ver só
uma coisa que por ironia eu na parede
com escrito esperança gigantesco
arco-íris assim colorido
aí eu entendi muito bem o conceito de
liberdade
eu queria ser rebelde estava tinha
perdido toda a minha liberdade com um
pouco de aus x no carro
aí eu saí de lá e meu pai me explicou o
conceito muito importante que é a
responsabilidade
falei agora você vai pagar o custo do
seu advogado e me colocou trabalhar numa
fábrica de janela
fiquei seis meses construindo janelas em
pvc
mas aí eu falei 'bom eu vou ainda por
estados unidos eu fui ao consulado
americano
fui tirar meu visto negado o meu visto
obviamente porque minha ficha policial
estava suja assim minha vida
de repente da perdigão sabe eu não sabia
mais para onde ir
aí eu decidi estudar em barcelona eu
fiquei um tempo na espanha estudará aí
me casei também que achava que nunca ia
me casar na minha vida com 21 anos eu me
casei
aí voltei para a itália quando voltei da
itália eu fiz outra banda e aí começamos
a tocar minhas músicas comecei a mostrar
minhas composições na roda
só que o dinheiro que eu fazia tocando
com a banda tocando rock'n essa não era
suficiente para fazer nada
aí comecei a fazer um monte de trabalho
eu fui garçom de bar eu fui garçom em um
restaurante foi jardineiro eu vendia
tíquetes por aí na estação de esqui que
a fui pintor de paredes por muito tempo
pintava casas das pessoas porque é muito
importante mas não era o que eu queria
fazer
em 2007 meu pai me obrigou a acabar o
conservatório porque eu tinha abandonado
o conservatório para estados unidos mas
como não foi meu pai meu brincou eu
acabei o conservatório
só que naquele na itália em 2007
aconteceu na crise econômica de bastante
na crise econômica social e não tinha
mais trabalho e mais dinheiro para fazer
nada
aí eu comecei a pensar que eu queria ir
embora e finalmente em 2012
eu fui embora da itália eu mudei para o
brasil isso porque a mulher que eu
estava casado é brasileira
aí mandei pro rio de janeiro chega no
rio de janeiro com 40 graus o tempo
abafado pra caramba e ou das montanhas
da gm quase morrendo de calor chegou lá
e não falava nem uma palavra de
português
nada nada e quando você não fala
português no rio de janeiro ocupam
começa a ser mais caro o leite é mais
caro
tudo fica mais cara entre essa tempo é
exclusivo para quem não fala português
aí eu aprendi muito rapidamente falar
português
depois mudei para minas gerais na
cidadezinha bem pequenininha que parecia
aquele vilarejo de onde eu vinha cansei
voltei para o rio de janeiro de novo e
quando voltei para o rio de janeiro
aconteceu um desastre foi o ponto mais
baixo da minha vida porque eu de repente
separei da minha mulher
fiquei sem dinheiro e fiquei em casa eu
lembro o dia que eu sair de casa depois
de uma briga quando uma malinha daquela
escola e assim de mão que cabe na
bagagem de mão de avião e o violoncelo
era tudo o que eu tinha na vida naquele
momento foi na rua assim aí foi
prontamente eu conheci uma pessoa que eu
comecei a tocar em duo com a minha amiga
cantora ela me hospedou na casa dela é o
momento de favor ou nada e meio na casa
dela
graças a deus e naquele ano e meio eu
entendi uma coisa que foi muito
importante eu fui tocar em todos os
lugares que eu encontrava
eu comecei a tocar na rua comecei a
tocar em qualquer barzinho com aquele
lugar onde me chamavam e é onde eu não
me chamava também eu ia
aí aconteceu que fui conhecendo uma
pessoa com esse novo conhecimento com
esse novo acontecendo é um dia eu fui
num sarau uns ao encontro de artistas
onde citou que há sim
aí fui lá porque algumas músicas globo
antes de ir embora chega na mulher do
meu lado e comece a me xingar o italiano
ela me chamou de filho de mais
desconhecida eu no caso manuela tomar no
lugar onde não num bate o sol mesmo e
isso foi nosso primeiro em primeiro
encontro assim eu não conhecia essa
mulher era meia hora depois a prazer
maria maria gadú e foi assim que eu
comecei a tocar com ela aquela noite
tocarmos a primeira música junto e
poucas semanas depois ela me chamou para
participar da banda dela aí tudo mudou
muito rapidamente e comecei a tocar em
vários teatros gigantescos no brasil
comecei a viajar muito e já confirmou
ser uma coisa incrível você não entende
por que você não toca gaita na sua vida
porque já conhece três nas costas é um
problema
aí eu comecei a tocar tocar tocar em
barzinhos
teatro tocamos em circunstância absurda
tipo toquei na festa de uma pessoa que
tinha ganhado na loteria
vocês já conheceram alguém que ganhou na
loteria eu achava que não existe isso
acredito eu tive a confirmação que não
existe as pessoas que ganham na loteria
mesmo aí começou a nossa nossa turnê e
amanhã para o público a produzir um
disco novo dela junto com ela
eu acho isso maravilhoso mas foi maria
eu nunca produziu um disco na minha vida
assim eu não sei fazer isso não vamos
fazer juntos
no final a gente lançar esse disco chama
vilã esse disco foi indicado ao grammy
latino como melhor disco de música
popular brasileira em 2015
aí eu achei que eu sabia quando se diz
que o agente
começamos a viajar com a turnê desse
disco até chegar e muito quando cheguei
montra no dia festivo de motor
eu tinha lembrado que dizia que queria
viajar o mundo quando tinha 14 anos com
a minha música eu tinha colocado nos
lugares onde eu queria tocar um montante
de r festiva
eu estava lá nesse palco no mesmo palco
onde não se tem disco de miles davis
corretor levado montanha é o mesmo outra
mesmo é aquele aí
foi incrível e também gostei tocar na
itália como um artista brasileiro fui
tocar na itália naquele dia fujo
eu achei trabalho na itália ainda no
brasil olha o mar é aquele dia meu pai
pela primeira vez se emocionou me tocar
e falou que eu tinha aprendido a tocar
para passar minhas emoções para os
outros ao invés de alimentar só meu
amigo e também depois eu tomei coragem
de fazer meu primeiro disco só que não
tinha dinheiro pra fazer meu disco eu
fiz na campanha de financiamento
coletivo na internet onde cada um paga
um pedaço até você chegar a uma quantia
de dinheiro que você precisa
aí um dia recebi uma ligação de uma
pessoa que não conhece o que você está
fazendo sua campanha de financiamento
coletivo para seu disco quanto dinheiro
falta para você alcançar seu objetivo
a falta de x em tamanho para essa conta
que eu te dou esse dinheiro é o que tá
maluco que você que então não tinha nada
mesmo você sabe quem é essa pessoa é a
mesma que ganhou uma terceira
essa pessoa realmente banco é o meu
disco é assim nasceu meu disco é com
todas essas aventuras nem atualmente
moro no rio de janeiro
saí daquele laranja de 1.200 habitantes
foi até o rio de janeiro
viajei o brasil voltei pra tocar na
itália agora eu tô aqui uma para
tocar e quando as pessoas perguntam de
fato do que eu tenho saudade
não tenho saudades em muita coisa na
minha vida desapego fácil manter uma
coisa é uma coisa da qual eu tenho
saudade mesmo essa não vai embora que é
das montanhas que não tem no brasil das
montanhas com a mesa em cima
[Música]
para a câmera
ae
[Música]
an é
é verdade
é
[Música]